Choice our ancestors could only dream of
modern supermarkets have it all that is
until they don't across the country
fruit and veg Isles are increasingly
bare Tesco has joined Aldi Asda and
Morrisons in introducing rationing
I don't suppose you've noticed vegetable
shortages yeah massive yeah yeah just
now were you looking for them
particularly or tomatoes they're a bit
insipid this time of year I think like
everything else I just go with the flow
and see what happens you know that's it
that's it pretty sanguine of you well
what else can we do babe
no Panic buying I would say as yet I
mean I've not walked in and been like
there is absolutely no food to be had
um it's just you know potentially buying
Alternatives or something different
shelves at this smaller grow so it
looked healthier but not for long the
owner told us his wholesale costs have
recently doubled there are two main
reasons for the shortages first bad
weather in parts of southern Europe and
North Africa places like Spain Tunisia
Morocco which the UK relies heavily on
at this time of year for most of our
salad crops secondly The Soaring cost of
energy has meant producers right here in
the UK have sharply reduced their own
production
and it may get worse before it gets
better the UK's largest tomato grower
has worn disruption could last until May
this year what's happened we've grown
because the last year's cup later it's
trying to cover some some value because
whatever has been squeezed on prices for
Not Just Energy but fertilizer labor
everything's gone up so we're going
later
um so we've started later and so instead
of starting end of March which will play
more like the end of April into May
in response at the national Farmers
Union conference the environment
secretary had this to say front page of
every newspaper is salad shortages Asda
rationing that will be I can't control
the weather in Spain either so uh that
went down badly in a room of farmers who
say energy subsidies would have
supported domestic production until that
starts to increase we're unlikely to see
the green shoots of recovery on our
shelves Matthew Thompson Sky News